aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous parler
d'innovation et de vie privée parce que
les deux sont pas souvent des choses
qu'on a l'impression de voir connecter
pour moi en fait c'est absolument
essentiel
j'ai une petite question à vous poser
est ce qu'il ya des gens ici qui se sont
déjà dit dans mes la vie privée de façon
mais donner je m'en fous parce que je
n'ai globalement rien à cacher oui bon
qu'ils considèrent être une personne
plutôt bien plutôt honnête dans sa vie
voilà ok donc évidemment qu'on n'a rien
à cacher puisque au final qu'est ce que
les gens vous découvrir moi je suis
quelqu'un de normal ma vie a rien de
spécifiquement particulièrement
intéressant on va faire un petit
expériences ainsi ça vous dit ok
prenez vos téléphones tout le monde
allait et ouvrez votre dernière
conversation ne choisissez pas la
conversation c'est pas important
n'importe quelle application de
messagerie ouvrez la dernière
conversation
donc c'est bon maintenant passer votre
téléphone votre voisin
ok
bon
ok ok combien combien combien combien de
personnes ici combien de personnes ici
on regardait la conversation du
téléphone qu'on leur a donné ok est ce
que je vous ai dit de regarder la
conversation et voilà combien de
personnes ici ont senti une petite
anxiété quand ils ont passé le téléphone
à son voisin voilà et encore vous
imaginez là la personne elle est à côté
de vous vous savez exactement qui sait
vous êtes capable de voir si elle fait
des choses qu'il n'est pas censé faire
avec vos messages maintenant dites vous
un truc à chaque fois vous dites ok à
une entreprise pour récupérer vos
données
vous êtes en train de faire ça en
réalité mme avec des gens que vous ne
connaissez pas donc vous ne connaissez
pas les véritables intérêts et contre
qui vous n'avez quasiment aucun recours
et pour moi ça c'est un vrai ça c'est un
vrai vrai vrai sujet aujourd'hui c'est
que on a complètement déconnecté
l'impact réel de notre des abus de vie
privée de notre utilisation de la
technologie
sauf qu'en fait dans les années 90 à
l'époque on était unplugged ont été
déconnectés finalement les questions
données personnelles c'était patron un
sujet parce qu'au bout il y avait un peu
de données à gauche à droite mais la
majorité de notre vie on la passe et
offline dont personne ne savait ce qui
se passait sauf qu'à chaque fois qu'on a
commencé à connecter un objet qu'on est
que de plus en plus de technologies on a
commencé à digitaliser de plus en plus
d'aspects de notre vie et le résultat
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on arrive
véritablement ce point d'inflexion où on
produit tellement de données
personnelles que tellement peu
d'entreprises centralise qu'on commence
véritablement à avoir toute notre vie
qui est exposé et c'est ça le vrai
danger c'est qu il ya vingt ans vous
aviez raison de dire que la question vie
privée était secondaire
mais aujourd'hui le monde a changé parce
que les données elles sont partout et ça
fait particulièrement peur quand je
commence à regarder des choses comme le
nombre de vols de données
1 et oui et encore ça c'est une
sélection ça ne représente pas toutes
les choses qui ont été volés alors
encore une fois vous pouvez vous dire
attendez s'il ya eu autant de données
volées qui lie à d'humains sur la
planète comment est-ce que ça se fait
que j'ai pas eu de soucis
et ben si il s'avère qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui ont aussi ce qu'on
appelle des reines somewhere c'est à
dire des hackers des pirates
informatiques qui avec ses données
volées vous envoyer un message en vous
disant vous m'envoyer des bitcoins où je
vais balancer à tout le monde
vos photos vous ai pas trop envie que
les gens voient donc quand vous donnez
vos données une entreprise en fait vous
êtes aussi en train d'en donner
potentiellement un hacker et ça va
peut-être vous coûter beaucoup d'argent
et si vous refusez de payer je peux vous
garantir qu'ils vont mettre ces
informations de manière publique donc ne
pensez pas que parce que ça ne vous est
jamais arrivé aujourd'hui que ça ne vous
arrivera pas dans le futur
donc pour moi les questions de vie
privée c'est déjà des questions de
sécurité
il faut qu'on puisse se sentir en
sécurité sur internet il faut pas qu'on
ait peur en permanence
2 qu'est ce qui va se passer qui va
voler nos données mais deuxièmement ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ces
entreprises au fur et à mesure de
collecter des données ne finisse pas
créer un profil tellement précis de qui
vous êtes qu'ils savent des choses sur
vous que vous n'arrivez même vous ne
pouvez pas l'imaginer moi l'autre jour
par exemple j'étais en train de parler
avec quelqu'un d'un livre je voulais
acheter
je l'avais même pas encore acheté et
j'ai une pub pour ce livre là à aucun
moment quelqu'un m'a entendu dire c'est
qu'en fait ce que j'ai cherché sur
internet est ce que mes amis ont cherché
sur internet a permis de dresser un
profil tellement précis qu'ils ont fini
par comprendre ce qui m'intéressait
c'est un peu comme un puzzle au final
savez au début quand vous commencez un
puzzle n'y a pas de trophée pas trop ce
qu'il ya dedans et à chaque fois vous
rajoutez une pièce ça devient de plus en
plus clair c'est exactement ce qui se
passe et que votre profil et vos données
personnelles est donc parfois c'est bien
d'avoir la personnalisation du targeting
par exemple dans le cadre de la santé
c'est important d'avoir une santé
personnalisés mais malheureusement la
plupart du temps c'est utilisé pour les
mauvaises raisons
c'est utilisé pour essayer de vous
garder captifs de ses différentes
plateformes
vous savez cette sensation quand vous
êtes sur instagram et goose crowley en
permanence et vous comprenez pas
pourquoi vous continuer à se creuser
comme ça comme quelqu'un de complètement
addict mais en fait c'est parce que vous
êtes tellement bien profilée que le
contenu qu'on vous montre est tellement
intéressant que vous finissez par en
fait ne jamais en avoir marre tout
simplement
malheureusement ça va plus loin il est
utilisé aussi des techniques de nage
pour vous pousser des publicités avec un
seul but qui n'est pas celui de vous
donner quelque chose dont vous avez
besoin mais véritablement de gagner de
l'argent de l'autre côté donc vos
données personnelles sont utilisés pour
du targeting publicitaires qui leur
permet de gagner de l'argent sauf que
dans la majorité des cas ce sont des
produits que vous n'avez pas forcément
besoin qui sont vendus par des
entreprises dont vous n'avez pas
forcément envie de faire du business
avec est malheureusement très souvent
que de l'argent que vous n'avez pas et
donc aujourd'hui pour moi le problème de
targeting c'est globalement des
problèmes en fait de manipulations et on
l'a vu aussi au niveau de cambridge et
attica quand il utilisait sa pour
manipuler des avis politique si je sais
exactement ce que vous aimez je sais
exactement que vous montrez pour vous
faire penser telle ou telle chose
ça s'est fait sur des échelles énorme
donc les questions de prix vie privée
sont fondamentalement des questions
d'addiction de manipulation et 40 hier
sa vie privée ses gardiens certaine
forme de liberté penser mais encore ça
c'est pas le pire dans cette histoire
moi ce qui me fait le plus peur c'est
qu'en fait on s'aperçoit que plus
quelqu'un utilise un réseau social - il
y adeux diversité dans le contenu qu'ils
voient c'est dire qu'au fur et à mesure
que vous donnez la donne est un réseau
social ou à une entreprise cette
entreprise vous connais tellement de
mieux en mieux qu'elle finit par vous
enfermer dans votre propre bulle et bien
évidemment c'est intéressant parce que
quand vous êtes dans votre propre bulle
tout est confortable vous vous sentez
bien c'est à l'aise vous reconnaissez
est pour moi le moment où ça se voit le
plus c'est quand ils les élections comme
par hasard tous mes copains il vote
comme moi ils sont tous les autres c'est
parce qu'en fait de l'algorithme c'est
ce que j'ai envie de voir
et plutôt que de risquer de me perdre
parce que j'ai vu quelque chose qui me
plaisait pas je vais tard gaieté et
c'est très très très très très dangereux
quand on commence à perdre la diversité
parce qu'en fait on sait aussi que
l'innovation vient de la diversité
il ya eu des études qui ont été faites
qui ont montré que les entreprises les
plus innovantes et et celles qui étaient
aussi les plus diverses
donc maintenant faisons un petit une
petite expérience de pensée imagine que
la couleur rouge représente le domaine
de la technologie
ok et vous vous êtes quelqu'un qui est
intéressé par la technologie
si à chaque fois que vous êtes exposés à
du contenu qui est du contenu
technologique
1 qu'est ce qui va se passer au bout
d'un moment bah vous allez juste en fait
finalement devenir un meilleur
technologistes ce qui peut être pas
mauvais vous devenez un plus grand
expert vous avez renforcer en fait vos
connaissances existantes
mais ici vous n'avez rien d'inventé de
nouveau vous n'avez fait qu approfondir
votre connaissance que vous aviez déjà
maintenant prenons un autre exemple
imaginons que cette fois-ci vous ayez
trois morceaux de contenus qu'ils soient
de la technologie mais que maintenant
vous commencez à regarder des choses
relatives à l'art vous savez c'est un
peu comme la pâte à modeler finalement
vous mettez du rouge et du vert ça fait
du jaune donc là maintenant à quelque
chose de nouveau c'est ni de l'art ceni
de la technologie c'est le genre
d'intersection et vous rajoutez le
business et maintenant tout d'un coup
vous avez tellement de diversité
d'informations que vous êtes capable de
voir le spectre entier vous n'êtes plus
enfermer dans le domaine que vous
connaissez déjà
vous avez maintenant la capacité de voir
ce qu'il se passe à l'intersection ces
différents domaines
sssa véritablement qu'on appelle
l'innovation finalement donc quand vous
êtes enfermé dans votre propre bulle
vous perdez votre capacité d'innover
parce que vous perdez cette capacité de
voir le spectre entier de ce qui est
possible et comment ces différentes
choses sont reliées entre elles et donc
pour moi les questions de vie privée
sont fondamentalement des questions
d'innovation et c'est très très très
important qu'on arrive à conserver notre
capacité d'innovation
alors comment faisons-nous pour garantir
la vie privée il ya pas mal de
technologies qui existent déjà il faut
comprendre le concept de privacy by
design le privacy by design c'est
véritablement cette idée qu'on va
garantir la vie privée
non pas en demandant à ce qu'on nous
fasse confiance mais plutôt en
garantissant au niveau technologique au
niveau produit au niveau business que
personne ne pourra jamais abusé de ces
données là donc par exemple le
chiffrement au moment où quelqu'un on a
parlé tout à l'heure c'est très simple
je veux utiliser un service mais je ne
veux pas dévoiler quoi que ce soit
imaginons vous vouliez récupérer des
recommandations restaurant mais vous
voulez pas que la personne de le coter
sache où vous êtes en ce moment ben vous
avez chiffré sur votre téléphone votre
localisation vous allez l'envoyer à
celui qui va vous faire les
recommandations qu'il n'a aucune idée de
là où vous êtes un parce que la donnée
chiffrée non pas la clé va moulinet un
espèce de résultat va vous renvoie le
résultat qui lui a même chiffré dont ils
ne savent même pas ce qu'ils vous ont
recommandé et vous allez le déchiffrer
sur votre téléphone
donc vous avez été capable d'avoir un
service en l'occurrence ici personnalisé
de recommandations de restaurants sans
jamais dévoiler là où vous êtes
et ce genre de technologie jusqu'à
récemment ça marchait pas très bien mais
maintenant ça y est on est à quelques
années de faire en sorte que ça marche
pour tous même l'intelligence
artificielle ensuite il ya les questions
de centralisation on ne veut surtout pas
qu'une seule entreprise et le monopole
sur toutes nos données
parce que ça ça veut dire que cette
entreprise déciderait de comment toutes
les personnes qui utilisent le service
devrait penser potentiellement est donc
là aussi il ya beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent notamment grâce à la bloque
chain à la décentralisation du pouvoir
en fait sur les données personnelles et
finalement il agit d p r c'est 50-50 qui
s'y trouve que c'est bien le gdr assez
bien assez bien aux etats unis c'est 0-1
les gens les aiment pas non c'est très
bien c'est très bien pour trois choses
c'est très bien parce que premièrement
ça permet de se faire oublier
donc si on n'est pas content on peut
partir et se fait oublier
deuxièmement ça permet de récupérer ces
données les envoyer ailleurs si vous
pensez qu entreprise a n'a pas les mêmes
valeurs éthiques que les vôtres mais
qu'une autre entreprise propose le même
service peuvent vous avez pas besoin de
recommencer à zéro vous pouvez
transférer vos données et finalement
dans certains cas il ya même le droit ou
non profilage si par exemple les
conséquences seraient extrêmement
lourdes sur votre ville et donc les
réglementations aujourd'hui qui rentre
en vigueur permettent de casser ce
cercle vicieux dans lequel on s'est
retrouvé avec les données personnelles
qui fait qu'on fini par renforcer sa
bulle sans aucun recours possible
derrière donc la cryptographie la bloque
chain la réglementation autour de
données personnelles sont des
instruments absolument nécessaire pour
protéger notre vie privée
alors pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle
de tout ça je vous parle de tout ça
parce que globalement aujourd'hui on a
un petit peu de choix pour le futur
on a celui là ok ça c'est le choix de
continuer comme on est en train de faire
maintenant c'est le choix auront
globalement on va dans le mur quoi si on
continue à s'enfermer dans le propre
bulle comment est-ce qu'on va
véritablement changer les choses tout le
monde voit bien fait on est d'accord que
les choses ne sont pas en train
d'avancer dans la bonne direction
il ya un moment faut peut être réalisé
que si on perd notre capacité
d'innovation
on va jamais réussir à empêcher ce genre
de catastrophe
est ce que vous avez envie d'aller vivre
sur mars parce qu'on en a qui proposent
ça comme solution potentiellement non
personne en vie sur mars je suis très
content de venir sur terre c'est super
belle planète il ya des belles plages
j'adore paris et j'ai pas envie d'aller
ailleurs
donc ce que moi j'essaie de proposer ici
c'est quelque chose de différent
ce que j'essaye de proposer c'est qu'on
arrive justement à créer un futur qui
soit véritablement positif un futur on a
réussi à résoudre tous ces problèmes
mais pour y arriver il va falloir
décupler nos facultés d'innovation grâce
à la technologie plutôt que de
s'enfermer dans une bulle qui va nous
conduire tout droit à une catastrophe
et c'est pour ça que tout le monde
devrait véritablement se battre pour
protéger la vie privée et pour casser le
cercle vicieux dans lequel nous sommes
depuis 30 ans merci
[Applaudissements]